Hola Raúl muy buenos días Pues ya están
Terminando de llegar acá a las
delegaciones tanto de Colombia como de
Venezuela sabemos que ya están acá el
ministro de comercio colombiano Germán
umaña también el ministro de transporte
Germán Reyes el presidente Gustavo Petro
todavía no ha robado acá al puente
internacional Simón Bolívar que es uno
de los cuatro pasos fronterizos entre
Colombia y Venezuela por la frontera de
Cúcuta hay mucha fuerza policial se
cerró el paso para las personas
temporalmente mientras se hace este acto
protocolario que iba a iniciar hacia las
nueve de la mañana pero que se ha
un poco por a la espera de la
llegada del presidente Gustavo Petro va
a haber Entonces el paso de un camión de
carga que representará entonces esta
normalización el primer paso de la
normalización de relaciones pero
nosotros estamos con Juan Carlos
Cárdenas él es el alcalde de bucaramanga
esta es una ciudad que si bien no es
fronteriza queda 190 kilómetros de acá
sí es muy importante porque ha sido la
que ha recogido una de las que ha
recogido tantos migrantes que ha llegado
desde Venezuela como reciben Entonces
esta reapertura que va a representar
para la gente de señor Juan Carlos bueno
primero que todo decirles con absoluto
cariño que es un momento muy importante
para nuestros pueblos colombianos y
venezolanos nuestra gente que es quien
realmente se ve afectado con este tipo
de decisiones pasadas de cierre de
frontera Esto va a permitir una
normalidad en las relaciones no
solamente de tipo económico sino también
educativo cultural y va a significar que
en la medida que esa relación sea normal
va a permitir de alguna manera generar
mayor beneficio en términos económicos
una economía formal una economía sobre
la mesa va a lograr reducir muchas olas
de inseguridad de inequidad y ese es el
gran propósito que los alcaldes y
alcaldesas que estamos comprometidos de
ciudades capitales a que esto sea una
realidad va a generar sin duda
territorios de paz territorios de
armonía territorios de bienestar y es el
gran propósito bueno Alcalde que sea
ustedes presidente también deja su
capital es a su capital es el gremio que
reúne a las capitales de los 32
departamentos de Colombia que va a
representar no solamente para para para
para buscar a maga sino para el resto de
capitales en términos también económicos
las ciudades capitales representamos en
Colombia un poco más del 100% la
economía de producto interno bruto son
más de un millón de hermanos venezolanos
que están en nuestras ciudades y sin
duda todos comprometidos porque hemos
logrado visibilizar en medio de la
pandemia en medio de todo lo que ha sido
el estallido social la crisis económica
que esta relación normalizada que fluya
con absoluta transparencia va a lograr
destrabar una cantidad de problemas que
tenemos sin duda Hay que ser capaces de
todo lo que tiene que ver la política
migratoria fortalecerla de que los
ciudadanos puedan tener su información
en términos de sus capacidades
económicas profesionales y que se puedan
reincorporar de una manera genuina a la
realidad económica no solamente de
Colombia sino también de Venezuela señor
Juan Carlos Cárdenas alcalde de
bucaramanga Muchas gracias Pues lo
cierto es que sí va a haber una especie
de restablecimiento también de
relaciones comerciales y porque antes
cuando había comercio entre Colombia y
Venezuela eran unos 7000 millones de
dólares anuales los que se transaban
entre ambos países ahora se espera por
parte de la presidencia de la república
que sean unos mil millones de dólares de
aquí a que termine este año y pues que
el tránsito de personas siga regular
unas 30.000 personas diarias que cruzan
por este Simón Bolívar puente
internacional Simón Bolívar una de las
fronteras entre Colombia y Venezuela
Daniela como siempre gracias por la
información más adelante vamos a volver
con usted para lo que sería Entonces el
inicio formal ya de este acto nos vamos
al lado venezolano está ya nuestra
enviada especial herminia Fernández
herminia estamos digamos no sé si ya
sabes Ya pocos minutos o cuando
iniciaría entonces este acto que tendría
lugar a las 10 de la mañana o sea
Digamos que ya tiene unos minutos de
retraso vamos a ver cuando va a comenzar
estamos en todo caso a la espera Y
entonces cuál es el ambiente de ese lado
de la frontera venezolana herminia
no sé si pueden detrás de mí Ah no acaba
de rodarse el camión ya vienen está la
fila de camiones son Sebastián que está
justo detrás Y son los 10 camiones o Esa
fue la cifra que dieron en principio
ambos gobiernos que pasarán por el
puente en breves minutos Acá está ya
todo listo también el área para la rueda
de prensa que será acá en Venezuela
luego de que está conformarlo simbólico
como se le llama llama los ciudadanos
dejaron ya de pasarnos transeúntes están
de la aduana hacia atrás esperando que
abran nuevamente el paso para seguir con
sus actividades normales también podemos
Escuchar juegos pirotécnicos del lado de
Venezuela porque los empresarios han
armado han organizado una especie de
celebración por esta apertura de la
frontera